[Music]  another Duggar is headed it down the  aisle Lauren said yes and reser prized  Wow 21 year old Josiah Duggar announced  the news that he popped the question -  Lauren Swanson in a video message on  TLC's website she is the one that just  sometimes just came upon you just like  she's the one this is it and I could  tell that we've worked really good  together we served together and yeah  just something funny I just know she's  the one the longtime friends just began  courting the Duggar family's version of  dating which includes some special rules  in January for us  courtship means just really good time  for us to focus on different things just  learning more about each other you know  with the goal of marriage in mind and  keeping that and just learning hey is  this really the one that is the one you  know  [Music]